I'm Joshua Burke and I'm from San
Gabriel California and I'm a
third-generation salt flats racer
I think my first trip up here was in
1985 and the first time I saw it I was
amazed she can't explain it to people
what the salt flats look like you have
to feel it fastest time gone probably
about 240 miles an hour that one's been
100 miles an hour on the freeway so you
know the sensation of speed once you go
to 50 then 100 feels like you're
trolling + 55 feels like you're going 5
miles now I was lucky to be born into
racing my father and my uncle both raced
on the salt flat and my grandfather has
made 60 consecutive barnacles so I'm
just following suit trying to follow his
example
you